bonsoir je vais vous raconter l'histoire
de l'écriture de mon premier roman qui
le met zéro vendu aujourd'hui à plus de
2 millions d'exemplaires et traduit en
23 langues alors je n'avais jamais écrit
de livres en réalité pour moi l'aventure
s'arrêtait au fait de l'écrit de
l'imprimer et de l'offrir aux gens que
j'aime mais avant ça j'aimerais vous
proposer une courte expérience ensemble
je vais vous demander de fermer les yeux
et de vous imaginer dans votre cuisine
voilà fermez les yeux et imaginez-vous
dans votre cuisine
vous décidez de vous faire un jus de
citron alors vous allez dans votre
réfrigérateur vous prenez un citron bien
frais vous le coupez en deux vous prenez
un presse-agrumes et vous commencez à
presser votre citron allez-y pressez le
bien puis vous prenez un verre vous
allez verser ce jus de citron dans le
verre santé
sentez bien et puis approchez ce verre
de vos lèvres et commencer à boire ce
jus de citron et puis croquer bien dans
les agrumes allez-y buvez d'un trait ce
jus de citron et croquez bien dans les
agrumes ouvrez les yeux
qui a ressenti comme de l'acidité un
frisson une réaction du corps
observer comme votre cerveau à la
capacité de vous tromper parce que vous
êtes d'accord avec moi personne n'a but
jus de citron et pourtant notre corps a
réagi comme si c'était vrai pourquoi et
bien simplement parce que notre cerveau
ne fait pas de différence entre le réel
et l'imaginaire
ce qui nous pose une première question
sommes-nous en train de vivre la réalité
nous sommes nous en train d'inventer et
si je montais d'un cran pourrait se
poser la question pour nos peurs nos
peurs sont-elles réelles ou le fruit de
notre imagination
ce qui m'importe ici c'est de se
rappeler réellement qui nous sommes
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec moi
pour dire que se reconnecter à soi c'est
déjà un premier pas vers le bonheur
alors c'est vrai on parle beaucoup du
bonheur il disait un article qui
explique que 95% des gens ont envie
d'être heureux
de vous à moi je ne sais pas à quoi
pense les 5% qui rêvent
95% des gens envie d'être heureux et
seulement 18% le son vraiment c'est à
dire moins d'une personne sur cinq alors
je me suis posé la question pourquoi
autant de décalages entre ces personnes
qui veulent être heureux et ceux qui le
sont vraiment mais peut-être parce qu'on
nous apprend pas à être heureux on nous
apprend les mathématiques on nous
apprend la physique on nous apprend à
nous tenir droit à dire bonjour à la
dame merci à son patron mais qui nous
apprend réellement à être heureux
personne
et parfois même nous sommes le fruit du
problème mais oui quand on se lance dans
un projet je suis trop grande je suis
trop petit je suis trop gros je trouve
maigre j'ai passé diplôme j'en ai trop
puis les enfants les crédits vous
l'entendez cette voix ou je suis
complètement folle
mais est-ce réellement notre voix ou
celle de notre ego
comment savoir si c'est la réalité ou
une illusion de votre cerveau tout le
travail va consister à identifier le
réel de l'imaginaire et pour ce faire il
va falloir apprendre à se reconnecter à
soi pour dépasser nos peurs et vivre la
vie qui nous inspire vraiment
laissez-moi vous ramener le 8 juin 2010
il est 16h je suis avec Alain mon
associé et nous venons devant notre
société à un géant du logiciel alors
vous riez entre acide belle confiance
sûre de moi
mais est-ce réellement la réalité
est-ce qui vous est déjà arrivé de vous
oubliez au point de ne plus ressentir
vos propres besoins pour un projet pour
une carrière pour une relation
sentimentale amicale même
tu dois être forte
ça c'est ce que je me répète tous les
jours et quand mes amis me disent mais
attends mode prends un peu de temps pour
toi repose-toi tu as l'air crevé non non
ça va aller je suis forte
mais au fond je sens que mon corps n'en
peux plus la fatigue les maux de tête
le pire dans tout ça c'est que j'ai
perdu mes propres valeurs je ne retrouve
plus le sens de ce que je fais et puis
quand on repousse sans cesse nos limites
quand on est aveuglé à ce point par la
fatigue on repousse ses limites encore
et encore
je suis Farré d'ailleurs de voir que
quand je fais une conférence et que je
j'interviens en entreprise et que je
pose la question qui a déjà vécu un burn
out ou un excès de fatigue mais la
plupart du temps la réponse est oui
c'est presque devenue commun
le problème c'est que ça a des
conséquences graves
le 11 novembre 2012 deux ans après avoir
fêté la vente de notre société à
Dassault
on annonce câlin mon associé est mort
d'une crise cardiaque
il allait avoir 50 ans alors je me dis
la prochaine c'est moi
et la prochaine ça devient des témoin
peu de temps après la mort d'Alain géme
et moi aussi fait un arrêt cardiaque et
là j'ai eu un électrochoc dans tous les
sens du terme d'ailleurs celui qui m'a
réanimé celui qui m'a permis de
comprendre que je devais apprendre à
vivre autrement c'est le point de départ
de tout je vais faire plusieurs voyages
dont deux au Népal
je me souviendrai toujours cette
conversation que j'ai eu avec karma mon
guide il s'appelait réellement karma
pour parler du destin c'est plutôt une
bonne chose
nous sommes sanctuaires des années pour
NAT 4000 mètres devant les plus hauts
sommets du monde et puis là je me tourne
vers mon guide et je lui dis tu sais car
moi je
j'ai l'impression que j'ai perdu le sens
de ce que je fais je sais pas ce que je
vais faire de ma vie alors Carma c'est
un guide de montagne il répond un peu
comme un moine alors il me dit tu vois
mode on vient de tout en bas on est
arrivé jusqu'ici un pas après un autre
oui c'est vrai d'ailleurs c'est
magnifique mais mais je sais pas ce que
je vais faire de ma vie
un pas après un autre commence par faire
silence
silence mais je sais même pas ce que ça
veut dire
alors maintenant que tu me parles du
silence c'est vrai que j'avais lu un
article
c'est toujours un peu embêtant de poser
une question et d'avoir en retour le
silence
il m'a fallu plusieurs jours pour
comprendre ce qu'il essayait de me dire
60 000 pensées tournent en moyenne dans
nos têtes chaque jour
pensées et 80% de ses pensées sont les
mêmes que la veille
le silence permet d'apaiser ce flux
automatique de pensée
60000 pensées et on sait pas lesquelles
choisir on sait pourtant que la solution
se trouve sans doute dans l'une d'entre
elles mais on peut pas la voir et on
sait même pas si ces pensées sont
réelles ou imaginaires
le silence permet de laisser remonter à
la surface qui est juste ce qui est
important
alors maintenant plusieurs fois par jour
je reste quelques instants en silence et
ça change tout
par exemple avant un rendez-vous
important je reste un peu en silence je
me concentre sur ma respiration et
naturellement les pensées s'apaisent je
vous invite à essayer d'ailleurs pas
besoin d'être un expert on parle même
pas de méditation
un petit peu quand même mais juste
rester en silence et observer ce qui se
passe
je vous invite par exemple la prochaine
fois que vous aurez une présentation à
faire devant vos collègues ou une
conversation qui vous stresse je vous
invite à vous poser à mettre un
chronomètre de 5 minutes et d'observer
ce flux automatique de pensée il y en a
une qui arrive laissez-la passer et
s'évanouir
vous allez me dire cinq minutes c'est un
peu long mais comme disent les
bouddhistes
tout le monde devrait méditer un quart
d'heure par jour et si tu as pas le
temps il faut une heure
c'est exactement ça c'est exactement ce
que voulait me dire karma et que je vous
invite à essayer par la suite
juste ce terre
alors on se connait pas encore très bien
mais moi je plutôt quelqu'un de bavard
et j'étais pas très à l'aise avec ces
histoires de silence et puis un jour
alors j'étais face à un magnifique lever
de soleil à force de pratiquer et bien
un jour mon cœur s'est exprimé et il m'a
dit Maud écrit un livre c'est venu comme
ça un peu comme un éclair Maude écrit un
livre
j'avais tendance à la mettre un peu de
côté parce que je savais pas trop quoi
en faire et puis je sais pas si ça vous
fait ça mais après on regrette on se dit
oh là là j'aurais dû m'écouter je le
savais alors cette fois-ci et ben j'ai
décidé de m'écouter je me lance je me
jette sur Google comment écrire un livre
alors là les réponses sont un peu
mitigées
impossible d'écrire un livre très très
difficile impossible de trouver un
éditeur en plus c'est tous des escrocs
98% des livres édités des passeront
jamais mis l'exemplaires vendus bref en
termes de motivation j'étais pas au
taquet
mais ça venait de plus loin et j'ai
décidé d'essayer quand même alors j'ai
écrit une phrase puis un chapitre puis
deux puis trois puis un jour je me
retrouve à côté de cette femme qui a
pour métier d'être plus elle écrit pour
les autres waouh c'est la première fois
que je rencontrais quelqu'un du milieu
alors je décide de me lancer je lui
demande est-ce que vous seriez d'accord
pour lire quelques lignes elle me dit
oui alors je lui montre et puis et puis
je la vois elle lit une dizaine de
lignes et elle referme le lit vraiment
regarde un petit Maude c'est nul
je vois le genre mais franchement vous
avez quel âge ça improvise pas d'être
écrivain
alors là je dois avouer que moi qui
était déjà pas tellement sûr de moi en
plus cette petite voix qui me rappelait
je serais absolument incapable d'écrire
un livre bon je dois avouer que là il
m'a mis complètement KO
puis je me suis rappelé des paroles de
mon guide karma quand on était au
sanctuaire des arrêts pour night il me
disait tu vois pour arriver jusqu'ici on
est monté puis on est descendu puis on
est remonté puis on est descendu un peu
vers la rivière pour remonter jusqu'en
haut il m'expliquait que pour apprendre
à marcher un enfant tombe en moyenne
2000 fois de tout son poids
tu tombes tu te relèves tu tombes tu te
relèves 2000 fois de tout ton poids ça
fait partie intégrante de ce processus
pour apprendre à marcher
le problème avec les bas c'est qu'on a
tendance à pas les accepter parce qu'on
les assimile à des échecs alors que la
réalité c'est qu'ils font partie
intégrante de ce processus
d'apprentissage vous savez un peu à
l'image d'un électrocardiogramme il y a
des hauts il y a des bas il y a des
hauts il y a des bases à l'horizontal
c'est que tu es mort
réussir
c'est se relever une fois de plus que
d'être tombé
en réalité nous avons à accepter ces bas
parce que nous ne sommes pas ce que les
autres pensent de nous nous ne sommes
pas non plus cette petite voix qui nous
raconte que nous ne sommes pas capables
non non n'écoutez pas soyez courageux
parce que le courage c'est un peu comme
un muscle plus vous allez l'entraîner
par la discipline et puis il va se
renforcer il va se développer
ce qu'on nous dit pas à propos de la
discipline c'est qu'elle est ennuyeuse
elle est fastidieuse mais il faut savoir
qu'il faut en moyenne 21 jours
pour prendre une habitude et à peu près
trois mois pour qu'elle s'installe
complètement dans nos vies
alors persévérer ne lâchez rien et je me
suis dit c'est lui qui a raison c'est
pas la première chute que je dois
abandonner alors maintenant quand
j'écris j'ai mis en place une routine
je me lève tôt le matin je reste
quelques instants en silence et puis
j'écris une phrase après une autre je
dis pas que c'est tous les jours facile
non non loin de là je dis pas non plus
que je doute pas bien sûr je doute bien
sûr que je procrastine souvent
d'ailleurs mais cette routine elle est
précieuse
je l'ai musclé elle est solide et je m'y
tiens je vous invite à faire la même
chose la prochaine fois que vous aurez
envie de vous lancer dans un projet mais
que cette petite voix viendra saboter
votre envie mettez en place une routine
c'est pas forcément de se lever tôt le
matin ça peut être l'après-midi même le
soir peu importe mais mettez en place
une routine et tenez vous y
la dernière chose que j'aimerais
partager avec vous et qui est sans doute
la plus facile à mettre en place
soyez heureux
émerveillez-vous éclatez-vous dans ce
que vous faites vous connaissez la
probabilité que nous avons de naître il
y a un chercheur comme ça qui s'est
amusé à calculer la probabilité que nous
avons de naître c'est une chance sur 700
trillions alors cette centrion c'est un
set et 14 0 derrière une chance sur 700
trillion
et pourtant on est là
la probabilité que nous avons donné une
chance sur cette centrion
alors profitez-en c'est comme si je vous
disais gagner au loto vous imaginez bien
une chance sur cette entrée c'est
beaucoup beaucoup moins que de gagner au
loto et pourtant si vous gagnez au loto
vous êtes d'accord avec moi vous n'allez
pas simplement payer vos cours ou
vos factures non vous allez vous éclater
vous allez profiter à fond
alors vous le savez maintenant
quand cette voix viendra sa beauté cette
envie
cette voix n'existe pas
elle n'existe pas elle n'est pas réelle
c'est une illusion de votre cerveau
alors la question que j'ai envie de vous
poser c'est quel est le livre que vous
allez écrire je vous parle pas forcément
d'un vrai livre je vous parle du livre
de votre vie parce que si vous écoutez
votre intuition
si vous faites une petite action chaque
jour avec enthousiasme avec motivation
et si vous acceptez de tomber même si on
vous critique même si on ne croit pas en
vous même si on croit pas en votre
projet vous en serez où vous dans 6 mois
dans un an dans deux ans
moi je vais vous dire je crois pas aux
recettes miracle mais j'ai l'intime
conviction que tirer les leçons de sa
vie et les partager avec les autres va
nous permettre de grandir tous ensemble
et mon plus grand rêve
ce serait que chacun se réalise dans ce
qu'il a de plus profond
alors je vous en prie
ne privez pas l'humanité de ce que vous
êtes merci infiniment